president biden says inflation is his
top priority but you wouldn't know it
price is skyrocketing to the highest
level in more than 30 years that's three
decades jessica
and joe is clampy claiming his recently
passed infrastructure bill is going to
fix the supply crisis and seems to blame
americans for buying too much stuff
not a lot of people are clear have a
clear understanding whether they have a
phd or they didn't go to school
about how a supply chain works because
of the strength of our economic recovery
american families have been able to buy
more products they're not going out to
dinner and lunch and going to
local bars because of covid so what are
they doing they're staying home they're
ordering online and they're buying
product this is a recipe for delays and
for higher prices and people are feeling
it
they're feeling it do you ever think
you've been paying this much for a guy a
gallon of gas
that is so comforting dana hey did you
ever think you'd pay this much under me
anyway i got to get back in the copter
and then he said um the sun's gone sun's
gone down so i gotta you guys are cold i
gotta go exactly so i will say with this
that uh there has i think there had been
a quite a bit of a disconnect between
what americans were caring about what
the administration was talking about
that had been going on for months
yesterday at least he did say i hear you
right prices are going up inflation is i
hear he hears all of that but then he
says but that's why we need to do this
build back better bill and when he says
people don't understand the supply chain
crisis i don't think that's true people
get it and they might not blame him
directly they might not say it's all his
fault but they do know this
if you have the government spend a whole
bunch more money in this situation it's
like giving too much medicine to a
toddler yeah it's not good for the
toddler i'm not saying well it does put
them to sleep yes
jessie how dare you because it really
works yeah it really works jesse i
i was thinking you might have a montage
to share greg who would have ever
thought we would have been paying so
much for gas roll it
that'll just tank the stock market and
you add gas prices to the top of that
surging close to 350 a gallon by this
summer if it's already up now 50 cents a
gallon from when biden was elected
nothing is worse in presidential
politics than high gas prices we don't
want high gas prices i could sure use
the money with these high gas prices let
me tell you i predicted 350 a gallon
today it is 340 a gallon so i did
predict that joe biden he's like the
kind of guy that sees on the weather
it's a 100 chance of rain he goes
outside without an umbrella and says how
did i get so wet i mean it's like it's
not that hard to understand when dana
said you pump 10 trillion dollars into
the economy between the fed and congress
you're gonna have high gas prices when
you stretch the supply chain all the way
across the specific and to china you
wonder why there's like an armada of
cargo ships sitting outside the port if
we had kept the factories here or even
in mexico we wouldn't have had that
problem i'd rather have made in mexico
at least than made in china but you know
what doesn't matter you have a phd it
doesn't matter if you have no degree
when things are expensive and
inconvenient you blame the guy at the
top and right now that happens to be joe
biden jessica as we all know you are
pregnant so you are buying gas for two
uh it's got to be uh difficult you have
more cargo to carry uh you have a supply
you might have a supply chain issue at
any moment we never know we had to get a
bigger car yes so i could fit exactly
what are your thoughts defend the
president or give us your thoughts
my thoughts first of all the malibu
armada is something really funny to
think about with all the cargo ships and
everyone waiting there
um i think dana's right that this turn
shows that
the elections last or two tuesday last
tuesday have made a difference in that
there has to be a reconfiguration of how
the messaging's working and there are a
bunch of moderate democrats have gone
out talking about this like abigail
spanberger was on the daily
uh talking about how we need a new
message we didn't hire joe biden to be
fdr etc what has been interesting though
is larry summers who's been very
critical of the president actually
defended buildback better saying that it
wasn't going to add to the inflation
problem and joe manchin released a
statement not connecting the two either
so that leaves that glimmer of hope that
it's going to get passed still but i
think going into this midterms it's
going to be the economy of the economy
that you know a couple more trillion is
not
going to hurt inflation i
i'm saying that there are key players in
this and people who have been very
critical of the president who are not
concerned you don't want that right well
i have a phd so
there you go and a baby
all right judge neither judge i
this might be the least most least
engaged president i've seen in my
lifetime no connection with anybody has
to be informed after the reporters ask a
question about something what was asked
he's not only the least engaged even
when he is engaged he's not engaged
okay this is a president who says we're
too stupid to understand what's behind
the supply chain crisis here's the
bottom line your standard of living is
going down everything costs more
trump said the price of gas would go up
it's going up and you know he's already
telling us that thanksgiving is going to
cost more than it did last year so we're
too stupid to understand that no we're
not he's too stupid to explain it and
too stupid to fix it there you go
the fastest up next hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else